Search is a big part of Android TV.
Let's see it in action, cat videos.
Neat right.
You can use search to expose
content from your app so
users can get to it straight
from the home screen.
Here's how search works.
Android TV shows search
results from Google,
as well as locally
installed searchable apps.
To make our apps searchable,
we implement a content provider to
provide search results for a query.
Android TV combines these results
into a search results page.
Users now have one click access
to launch content you return,
using a pending intent you provide.
For this to work,
we'll have to map our data into a cursor
format that's expected by the system.
If you've previously worked with
search on Android, for example,
on a mobile device, then you should know
that Android TV uses exactly the same
search interface that you might have
already built for another form factor.
In this section I'll describe
the key steps involved, and
you can check out the instructor
notes for more detail.
Before we go any further,
we should talk about privacy.
Protecting user privacy is key, and many
users consider their activities on TV,
including searches,
to be private information.
Here are two tips, never send personal
information over the network.
For example, if a user is searching for
a pizza restaurant near them,
you don't need to send their user ID to
the server, along with their zip code.
Now in the rare case that you
have to send personal info,
you should never log it.
And if for some reason you do have to
log it, then you should protect that
data extremely carefully and
erase it as soon as possible.
Also be sure to provide users with an
easy way to clear their search history.
The first step is to define an activity
to respond to the search request.
Here we are inside of our manifest.
The first step will be to define
an activity that will be launched
when the user selects one of our
results from the TV home screen.
We declare this activity to accept
the action.SEARCH intent using this
intent-filter.
We also have to specify
the search configuration to use
using this meta data element and
this XML.
You can find this data inside
of searchable.xml, and
see the instructor notes for
a description of the fields.
Now, when our
MovieDetailsActivity is launched,
we need to resolve the search data and
display the corresponding movie.
You can see how we do that inside
the checkGlobalSearchIntent method.
Here we check to see if the intent
action corresponds to global search, and
if so, we pull the selected
movie id out of the intent.
Next we need to define a content
provider which returns search results
to the Android TV search dialogue.
We only need to implement a part of it,
and
the necessary columns
are already defined by the SDK.
And, you can find a step by step
guide for building a ContentProvider
in the instructor notes or
the Android Fundamentals course.
First, let's define
a ContentProvider in the manifest.
Here we'll use the VideoContentProvider.
Also make sure that
exported is set to true so
Android TV global search
can use the results.
You should see
the instructor results for
more info about securing
your ContentProvider.
Here we are inside our
VideoContentProvider, and
the first step is to
implement the query method.
Now, usually this takes five arguments.
Our provider though, only needs
to provide search results, and
the only argument we need
to handle is selectionArgs.
This contains the search
terms from the user.
Because of the way we configured out
searchable.xml, it will only contain
a single element which represents
the entire search string.
The last thing we need to do to finish
our search provider, is to pack
the search results into the cursor
format that's expected by Android TV.
The data fields expected are represented
as columns of a SQL like database.
And regardless of your
data's original format,
you must map your data
fields to these columns.
You can find a description of all
of these in the instructor notes.
To polish your search results,
you can also add a Watch Action Link.
As you can see here, this search
result actually came from Google.
But when a use clicks this button,
it will launch your app.
In order for this to work,
these three field return by your search
data much match those from Google.
When these three fields match,
Android TV will automatically attach
the Watch Action Link to
the search result card.
So it's in your favor to
provide accurate metadata
with your search results.
There's one last thing you can
do to polish your app, and
here's in app search.
Notice that here we've added the search
button to the browse fragment.
At this point we've already got our
ContentProvider working, and all we
have to do is add a fragment provided
by the Leanback Support Library.
That fragment is the search fragment,
and
you can see details on how to
use it in the instructor notes.
The pattern is exactly the same as
we've seen previously in this course.